[Music]
finally off the road with my band and
back in my beautiful city of Nashville
we're going to start the day off here at
Brie's two-parters with a hot cup of mud
right now man got that espresso on milk
here for anything good to see you again
this place has got a killer vibe I
didn't think this explosion and coffee
out when you get a bunch of creative
people together a bunch of passionate
people together they need coffee the
coffee shop can end up being like the
water cooler for the city you know so
Nashville is a city built on music
residents definitely filled now by the
culture they go hand-in-hand a woman up
here they were here at Peter nappies now
this is one of Nashville's best handmade
shoe stores
that's one it's called the Juliet at the
leather it comes from hundred-year-old
gin match from Eastern Europe Oh what
started working in shoe stores when I
was 19 and then it evolved where I was
sketching and designing I had the
opportunity to move to Italy and study
the craft to learn how to make shoes by
hand
I saw the research and things about my
grandfather and my family I found out
that my snappy family had been making
shoes next village for about 200 years
you need to know that game on that Wow
we need to come out with a care based
appeal to rather than live it
[Music]
one of my favorite stress relievers in
Nashville is to come see Gigi at hat
wear come on in you can come in here and
create your own design because
everybody's different
you know I want people to put their
personality into the Hat and help create
and co-create people say it's cowboy
hats and boots but there's so much more
when we really see all kinds of people
and all kinds of people would have had a
cool industrial part of town going into
Bastion to get some good food some good
drinks play some game this one we have a
almost like a sashimi sort of dish we've
got a small turbo so it's like a flat
finish almost like a tiny politics and
all cauliflower it's and grapes
yourselves and then this is a like a
ponzu it made with soy and like a ham
broth and it collect you're eating sushi
and got a little bit of Tennessee and
there's about yeah so the nine bastions
obviously unique weird where did you get
that where you come from and I was
looking through an old cookbook and
there was this line of cookbook that
said in a world of increasing automation
the restaurant is the last bastion of
fundamentally human labor fundamentally
human labor you know the world was
becoming more and more automated you
don't buy things from the store any
money buy things on Amazon what we do in
a restaurant you can only experience in
a restaurant you can't do it at home do
you all have a new system we do is just
don't be an [ __ ] you know what I
think I think you know sometimes to go
to a restaurant people forget about that
you know
[Music]
we're in East Nashville at this cool
barber shop called Scouts we'll get a
freshen up before a blast out on the
road having noticed the kind of
evolution into a call back to
craftsmanship I think I ought to do with
our southern hospitality and our roots
go back to that we really enjoy getting
the community involved and we do eat
parties like every three or so moon
we're in a big city in Nashville but
it's still feel small you know
[Music]
this is wearing one of my favorite spots
in East Nashville MIDI knows there's
there's nothing special but everything
special you know what I mean these
little places that have been owned by
the same people for years and years and
years they're blowing up you see your
friends from the road in here the
beautiful cars like the city can have
one more bit a piece turn into work I
will just tie my ribbon why do you think
people want to come here
maybe cuz they know exactly what's this
and we do one thing really well and so
that's why can you keep coming back
maybe the best everyone do it well you
know what's cool about today like all
the spots that we've hit up those people
are the best at what they do they stay
in their Lane they love doing what they
do and the people that come experience
it feel it just part of what makes
Nashville Nashville part of what makes
me mean if you want to come come
experience yourself don't all come in
one time you want to keep it cool
[Music]